there's only one word for what happened
Game Changer it's going to affect every
aspect of the watch world every
attribute the one thing I know is
certainty and Sonia John nothing happens
overnight in the watch industry this is
the slowest moving industry on Earth and
they're proud of it
[Music]
welcome Mr wonderful thank you so much
John I am going to keep this
introduction short and sweet because you
are truly a man who does not need an
introduction because if you've ever
watched television you've watched Shark
Tank which is happens to be my favorite
television show well thank you born in
Canada Uh Kevin O'Leary spent his early
years as an international Globetrotter
and even lived in the great city of
Geneva which may have inspired your
passion for watchmaking and we'll talk
about that shortly
you're known for your unique ability to
combine your business sense with common
sense and most notably an unmatched way
of delivering a clear message to
aspiring entrepreneurs which I have some
questions about that sure too
uh no matter how painfully honest those
comments might be
today we're going to challenge you
to Pivot 100 of your messaging to the
collecting World specifically the watch
collecting world and explore the world
of virology in a way that has never been
done before so welcome Gavin thank you
so much looking forward to it and of
course you're a legend too John let's
face it ah I mean in the world of Patek
Philippe is there any brand bigger than
yours outside of Patek the brand itself
I don't think so not for collectors I
absolutely have wholehearted love for
watches in particular Patek Philippe
it's obvious but today we're going to be
talking about some other brands too and
I can't wait to dig into that with you
but my first question is simple why
watches
you know I I think I fell in love with
watches in my teenage years because of
what you mentioned earlier my stepfather
moved to Geneva Switzerland and so on
the lake lemon or Lake Geneva depending
what you call it you find some of the
original measles right there and so if
you're a young boy walking down the
streets you're looking in at Patek
philippes or Rolexes or APS or all the
other Boutique watchmakers and all of
the brands in Europe that have such
unique dials it became a fascination
with watches as art because I've always
as a collector never been driven into
the technical nature of caliber I've
always been a dial guy and that came
from Geneva walking the streets of
Geneva when I saw the first Submariner I
just went out of my mind I fell in love
with it and the moon watch in the 70s by
Omega my very first piece
every kid that read you know any
engineering magazine or had any kind of
a hobby or was interested in space
wanted that Omega watch and it's gone on
to be one of my legendary Holdings in my
portfolio and each watch of course has a
story and through the 70s and 80s and
90s I didn't stop I just kept going now
you've described it as incurable disease
watch collecting is the just disease
that just cannot be cured is that true
no it's true it's a virus it is a virus
and it it there's some Rules of
Engagement when you get that disease
that you need to understand and I've
said this to younger collectors you know
that I talk to all the time about this
first of all you know
I picked up a new piece today we'll talk
about it in a moment but
my wife has tried to seek professional
help for me and said you've got to stop
this there's nowhere to put these
anymore
there's you can't wear them in a year if
you even tried to if you if you wore
multiple watches a day
this has to stop I mean it's clearly a
problem and then I show her
how much they've appreciated and how
they're beating our stock portfolio our
bond portfolio our real estate portfolio
and you know that still doesn't
have her she won't stand down and I said
look this is the one thing that that I
just can't change and I'm very fortunate
um you know I've been able to afford
these watches so the most important
thing to know when you get the virus at
a young age which often happens is never
borrow money to buy a watch never never
go into debt to buy a watch you have to
buy within your means and your
collection will change as your means
change and if you're successful and you
work hard and maybe you have to be lucky
sometimes you will be able to get
everywhere you want to go with watch
collecting and and so you know there's
some Rules of Engagement here but
obviously I'm you know I'm amazed at
each year the the new dials that I find
all around the world and I have to look
in the context of my collection of
something that is a is a is a portfolio
of art that's what it is and and it's
treated me well financially but make no
mistake it is a virus and unfortunately
uncurable this disease has been good for
you is that fair to say very good
disease
so let's talk about the market you've
mastered financial literacy and arguably
mastered or logical literacy at the same
time and you use your various platforms
to promote both but I'm very curious in
the conversations you have when the
camera is not rolling and I hope to draw
some stories from you today
first with conversations that you have
with fellow watch collectors
you're at dinner you're on the phone
what are you talking about with fellow
watch collectors so you're right there
is a unique Global Community you're part
of it in in watch collecting and it's a
it's a Sisterhood A brotherhood it's
it's people from all walks of life
all different countries
and when we talk about watches we leave
politics aside we leave gender we leave
race we leave everything aside and we
focus on horology the art of making
watches because after all at the end of
the day nobody needs a watch you don't
need a watch anymore to tell time you
buy it because you love it and you love
the art of making it and you respect the
man or woman who gave up their lives
their entire careers at the age of 14
onward as you know how hard it is to
become a master watchmaker to honor them
and and and be their payroll and so what
I'm almost interested in in talking to a
close of fear if anybody he's the
world's greatest largest watch collector
for sure I met with him recently for
lunch in Dubai with another uh of the um
UAE friends I have and we just sat for
three hours we were going to only meet
for half an hour we were still there
almost four hours later just talking
about close experiences what he's done
with his one-of-a-kind collections some
of the pieces I've received recently
debating you know what's new with Patek
what's going on with Rolex FP journ all
of these discussions once you get into
that narrative time just flows it's like
if you ever watch in the Middle East
people underneath an olive tree playing
baccarat or any game
or bull in France the hours just go by
it's no different in talking about
watches
I've said this before but if you go back
to the old west picture group of cowboys
sitting around a fire connecting and
sharing stories about their day I look
at these as like the modern day fire
they were surrounded and we discuss we
break bread over and we connect we share
our emotion we share Stories We Share
Adventure we share sadness happiness
it's it's really it's a beautiful thing
watch collecting the way it connects
people well each each watch and this is
a good example this is just a fraction
of my portfolio but each watch has a
unique story and I remember every piece
as if it's one of my children and how I
got it why I got it where it fits
because I'm a dial guy I'm always
seeking the next dial what's next what's
next where are we going next you know
and some of my friends that are
collectors are really into the hardcore
technology trying to collect verticals
of calibers or but everybody has their
own reasoning but I'm just straight
dials when I see something that is a
unique dial that I've never seen before
it doesn't matter to me what the price
is it's what's the story of the piece
who designed that dial where did it come
from what was the motivation for that
and the last thing I worry about is the
price because I'm not going to buy it at
any price if the dial doesn't fit into
the calexio like where does it fit where
is it why is it here what makes it
unique why does it have a position with
all the other dials because just buying
the same thing over and over again to me
is not watch collecting now I imagine
that is a conversation you're having
with many other friends that happen to
be CEOs or owners of watch companies
auction houses important retailers so
moving away from fellow collectors I
want to know the conversations you have
with the decision makers in the industry
and what are you challenging them when
you're sitting face to face with them
and what are you asking them I am I
often attend the Philips auction online
or in person here in New York I've
recently bought a very unique there the
first thing I do pragmatically in an
auction is to find out if Claude Sofia
is bidding yes because bidding forget it
forget it yes
sure there's just you have to respect
who he is and and if he wants the peace
he's going to get the peace and there's
nothing you can do about it and there's
not only a price bias every Auctioneer
in the world knows quote and they want
to because he does he is the number one
honored guy and that's it and I get it
now when there are scraps to the rest of
us that's where we compete and I also
know that his collection is vast so that
if he's already got the piece you're not
gonna have to compete with him but if
it's a one of a kind I do my checking to
the back doors clone online or whatever
and you know I asked the auctioneer
because I know most of them and say look
where are we standing with this thing
and do I have a chance now I can bid
against anybody else I'm not worried
about that but not Claude that's it but
yes I always challenge them to bring new
unique pieces and lately a trend that
started recently and it was again
manifested itself last December at the
Phillips auction they went to a major
Museum in this case chopard and they
commissioned a one-of-a-kind piece with
a unique artist to carve The Laughing
Mexican skull piece that was only going
to show up in the auction it's never
been owned it's a it's a one-of-a-kind
made by chopar for the auction for
charity and I was I held the piece days
earlier I wasn't going to bid on it
until I actually held it and I went oh
my goodness this piece is insane and and
I have to have it so you know Paul
Boutros was there I was nervous about
Claude luckily he didn't step in I ended
up I think I was
competing against two Chinese gentlemen
but you know when you get in your head
you want the piece you want the piece
that is the beauty of auction that is
the beauty of auction and I you know I
like to think I didn't overpay for it
but who knows but it'll be in my
portfolio forever and it has already
been you know this it generated so much
conversations what I love about a dial
is you wear the piece out you don't tell
anybody what it is you go into a room
you sit down beside somebody and they
look at and say what the hell is that
how do you tell time with that where did
that come from why is that a skull all
of that
and the answer there it is that watch
did its job it started a conversation
and that's the beauty when you show a
watch to a non-watch collector you can
bring them into your world and dials are
the Gateway I mean that's the first if
you try to explain a tourbillon to
someone who doesn't have a horological
there's no exciting or turbulent
technically we don't need turbios
anymore other than their beauty and what
they what they tell you and how they
manifest themselves into a dial it's
Unique but the turbo is a technology
that was should have been abandoned in
1955 but still around see you are a man
that knows a great deal and the deal
that everyone's talking about today is
Rolex acquiring the celebrated retailer
Booker yeah this is something that's
extraordinary they have a hundred stores
around the world uh understand 53 have
Rolex and 48 have tutor and now Rolex
actually owns Booker what do you think
of this deal deal and how will it change
the world
there's only one word for what happened
Game Changer it's going to affect every
aspect of the watch world every
attribute it's going to change how
collectors feel
it's going to change how the aftermarket
works it's going to change accreditation
and insurance and
all kinds of issues are going to get
manifested in in this verticalization I
mean there's other Industries where it
takes decades and it certainly has taken
over 100 years here for this to happen
but if you think of the legacy of of
buchar and Rolex from the earliest days
if there was a relationship torturous at
times but in the watch world as you well
know John respect is everything it's
everything Heritage is everything
history is everything
it's all part of the fiber and the DNA
of how this industry works and and when
when people come to me that don't
understand this
they get themselves in trouble
you know I'll give you an example
somebody says to me well I just got
allocated this really important piece
from XYZ Brian wouldn't mentioned the
brand and I got a crazy offer for it and
I flipped it the next day
he just signed his death certificate
or she they will never be collectors
they will be blackballed in perpetuity
during their lives if they didn't
understand that they never had a chance
in the first place so you don't go into
this not understanding the rules you
have to adapt to
this incredible environment this unique
industry
The Rules of Engagement aren't even
written they're understood and and
spoken around that proverbial campfire
you talked about you don't mess with the
Primal forces of the brands they've been
around longer than you have and you
cannot mess with them and and you have
to respect them and they have to slowly
build you have to solely build that
relationship with them it takes decades
to finally get to a place where you can
one day sit down with one of them say
will you make me a one-of-a-kind piece
that's the upper end that's your journey
I'm there now it took me forever I'm
actually 210 years old Mr Wonderful here
and there's no debate about this small
businesses in America create over 60
percent of the jobs but times are tough
is there a solution yes the government
employee retention credit program go to
wondertrust.com today you're saying very
clearly it's not just about money in the
watch world it's about relationships and
these Rules of Engagement of how you
connect with their retailer and
ultimately the brand are key to being
able to put together an important
collection I would say it has nothing to
do with money nothing it has a lot to do
with respect and Trust
you won't get allocations you want
unless the retailer
the brand
trust you and respect you and know where
you're going with it
you if you have to earn that that takes
forever and they will never tell you
when you have it the only way you can
measure it is when you get to that place
where one day a watchmaker says you know
your collection is is interesting
would you consider a one-of-a-kind piece
you know it's you you and in allocations
I tell people that are barking at me
please get me this please get me that
you only ask once
you never ask again
if you start nagging them and calling
them and emailing them and texting them
you go right back to the bottom of the
list and if you don't understand that
you're not a watch collapor I'm so glad
you said that and I've never heard a
collector put it so clearly I think the
Swiss Watch industry will thank you for
making it very clear don't be annoying
don't be a nag you don't deserve
anything no matter how big your
collection is
you're honored to get that allocation
you're honored you're always honored if
you don't understand that if you're
arrogant about it
you lose all the equity you built and if
you go ahead and sell a watch to make a
few bucks and then go ask for something
special I I can't I'm in in my in when I
have a nightmare I wake up thinking a
soul to watch I mean I just would never
do that
ever and everybody knows that about me
ever would I ever do that
and when I die all of these watches are
coming into my coffin and coming with me
to the afterlife I'm going to be buried
in a pyramid somewhere and so my son has
been licking his chops at this
collection and Paul boutro stalking to
my wife about it no everything's coming
with me I think you're gonna need extra
extra concrete around that too and 24
hour security but now I have a question
which is a bit sensitive but I'm sure
our friends of Rolex will will listen
imagine you're the CEO of Rolex what
would you do differently or what would
you do the same today
well
Rolex is unique as you know it's the
world's largest watchmaker and probably
the in some ways the premier brand it's
for me you know it depends who you talk
to of course but
I think what Rolex is going to do and
I'm speculating like everybody else is
is do nothing
they're probably for a long time going
to leave to renewable career alone
they're going to operate at arm's length
because think about the other
relationships inside of one of these
here in New York
you know the time machine or any of
these the meat packing District it's got
a huge there's other brands that survive
on those shelves
Patek I buy my potato
they're not going to want to lose that
relationship overnight I'm sure they
won't but
what they're doing is establishing a
unique business model for the 100 next
hundred years and 100 years after that
because the one thing about watches that
people have learned even during the
pandemic and even during the move of the
internet
it's not just online the experience of
going in to see the peace
to sit and look at different options and
dials hold them spend hours with them
drink a glass of Bordeaux burgundy or
Pinot with them
go outside for the fresh air come back
in
where the piece
sometimes you're making
huge financial decisions because you're
buying a you know a very unique
important piece from a Patek for example
you don't do that online you need the
experience that atmosphere
that these remarkable call them museums
like when I go into these tour no stores
they spend Millions creating that
environment
and I respect them for it and I want to
pick up my piece there I want the whole
essence of when I receive that watch it
becomes part of its history and I go
through that
all the time and so I think
Rolex totally gets that whether you go
into Geneva or you go to Dubai or
wherever you go in the world
Miami New York
when you walk in that store it's the
same atmosphere they've nailed it years
ago they're not going to change that so
imagine you're one of the decision
makers and protectively management in
Geneva and all of a sudden patekeep
watches are being sold through Rolex
owned retailers how do you feel about
that and what do you do
well we've seen this movie before we've
watched it happen recently in the last
seven years with ap where they had many
relationships with retailers
particularly here in the U.S
and they changed their minds under fresh
was watch uh he has allowed a few to
exist but he's brought the whole thing
in-house and he's decided that if you're
going to collect AP you're going to have
a direct relationship with the brand
I'm not sure
Patek will go in that direction
Patek is such a sought after brand by
collectors
and individuals I mean it it's a brand
that has
it's one of the three Horsemen and when
I say three Horsemen I mean Rolex 8p
Patek and so
I don't think I think if that's another
situation where they're going to do
nothing they're going to just keep that
relationship
the one thing I know is certainty is
sodium John nothing happens overnight in
the watch industry this is the slowest
moving industry on Earth and they're
proud of it they would rather move slow
think decisions for decades before they
make a move and still there's an
insatiable demand for their product so
how distribution channels work how
retail works today tomorrow 10 years 20
years is not going to stop the demand of
people like me I'm going to play ball
with them no matter how they want to
play ball because I'm part of that
Passion Play that dance that DNA I'm
just one collector there are millions of
people like me and
you know we watch this world go by
and we're going to integrate in no
matter what direction they take so I'm
not but one thing I've learned about
Rolex they don't make many mistakes
historically they've gotten it right
yeah time and time again and same with
Patek affiliated
an AP has fundamentally changed over the
last 20 years as time will tell yes but
it does the demand for a for AP
insatiable insatiable you know
I'll tell you a story I was in um
in the AP Boutique a few weeks ago
uh
in
in Miami was announced a few months ago
picking up a watch that I'd worked on
for two and a half years with the team
in in Geneva a one of a kind
uh piece
it's right here
there's only one of these in the world
an open work Royal Oak
I was picking it up
and I was I have to tell you to be truth
that it's it's out there I was moved to
tears I've been worked on it for so long
and I finally held it in my hand it was
just an emotional moment for me
and later we made some adjustments
because it has a one-of-a-kind Red Band
I brought my wife with me and she said
wow
I like that
I'd like one too and I said that's not
gonna happen
however you don't want to you don't want
the same size style they have other
women based watches she fell in love
with the look of a Royal Oak and now
she's wearing one I was very fortunate
to be able to get another one but it was
not it was it was a production watch but
she loves it
that happened in the personal experience
of holding this piece you can't do it
online you can never do justice with a
picture of a watching your phone you
gotta hold it and that's what happened
to my wife and now she's crazy for AP
which is a horrible thing for me we
don't want two people in the family with
the same virus it might be competing
against their problem it's a problem
let's explore that emotion that you feel
when you receive a watch that you've
been working on waiting for for so long
where's that emotion from is it
something from your childhood
remembering walking the streets of
Geneva is it a moment of being proud of
something you've obtained is it to
celebrating the moment in itself where
is it coming from for me it's joining
the camaraderie of other people that
have
already shown their appreciation for
that brand that watch that caliber that
that dial so I can be part of that
community and so you know when I look at
something like this FP Journal
this watch was an entry level uh 20
years ago very hard to make this piece
it's now impossible to get I run into
people all around the world that have
this pace it's rumored to be Putin's
watch I don't know if you ever heard
that story I have and um
we are part of a unique we don't have to
say anything to each other when we so
for me emotionally when I when I wear
that watch I'm now part of a unique
Brotherhood or Sisterhood no matter how
you want to look at it of men and women
that have said this is part of who I am
now and this is part of my story and
watch collecting and that's how I feel
about every piece I get stopped all the
time
usually it's two questions please sell
me that watch which of course you know
my answer it's it's like selling I can't
sell you in my hand I'm keeping this
it's part of me it's it's in my DNA
but very often it's someone who just
comes up to me
pulls back his cuff is wearing the same
piece
and that's all we say we kind of respect
respect that's it I was in the elevator
once wearing my Aquanaut another
gentleman had the same watch on it was
just the knot of respect we didn't even
say anything if you have an aquanon and
I have luckily to have them
I mean they are impossible to get yes
and
my Aquanauts are
from my original retail purchase so I'm
so proud of I've never had to go to the
secondary market for those and and now
if you have to my goodness the prices
are insane but still they appreciate and
so
I really look to own a piece like a 5711
is now priceless
I mean I was very fortunate to buy it
when it was a production watch and so
it's become you know for Patek for me a
a unique unique offering and you know
let me show you something else John this
is
not an expensive watch this is a Tiffany
you'll notice something very strange
about the bottom of that dial
two what does that say
727 that is not what should be there but
that is the address of their new store
in New York that's brilliant
blue Tiffany on the back they made a few
pieces I'm very honored to have one I
wore this on the set of shark tank in
the uh recent June pod and Barbara
Cochran was to my right said
that's my favorite watch you will and
she's seen a few watches it just shows
you dials tell a story and when she
realized what was going on she went out
of her mind she said you must be kidding
me
I was fantastic I haven't seen that
watch before yeah no I mean it's it's
it's it's a quartz watch it's no
different than an elegant from an FPS
short but it's a dial that tells a story
and again it starts a conversation in
that case with Barbara here's another
piece I wanted to show you where we're
walking through some of the watches I
brought you'll recognize this as a tutor
a classic look it's made from Silver
Tudor has recently gone into new
materials and they have done a lot of
work in brass and in silver I wore this
again Shooting Shark Tank it became the
the
this the production staff's favorite
piece they fell in love with it I mean
you wear it every day it's a beautiful
watch
but I'll tell you what moved me about it
afterwards after that pod and everybody
coming up was saying can I get one of
those where did you get that what's the
story on this piece which is again a
conversation starting I realized because
I've been thinking about this for a long
time
tutor once in a while create a Founder
series of watches and I went to Adam
here the the US CEO for tutor and said
would you ever consider if I
commissioned it making
a unique one-of-a-kind Shark Tank tutor
with a shark tank logo if we get the
rice from Sony and engrave on the back
the individual's name and a unique
serial number he said we'll do it we'll
do it so we found the first 23 people
that were there the day the pilot was
shot and those watches are in production
I will be giving those out next year
again being a payroll and I'm buying
that for my honored you know
make one for charity and they will
auction it at the
Paul Boutros Phillips auction December
he said no
there's not a Founder associated with
that piece
the answer is no
I respect that decision I totally
respect it I did not whine about it I
said yes sir you got it he said I want
to know every single name
on every piece and I want a list of
those people and I want you to prove to
me that they were Founders which I did I
love it yeah again great that shows you
that how he commands the brand how he
understands his brand and how he
protects his brand and what he's done
with that tuna brand that thing I never
owned a tutor until I met with him at
the Meatpacking uh Rolex boutique where
they haven't you know a sub Boutique
inside it that guy sold me three watches
he's the best salesman they have that's
spectacular yeah
our watch is an asset class
I Mark to Market my watches you using
software and auction prices what I do is
I look at the mean auction price each
night I do this automatically with
software deduct 20 and Mark to Market at
that price for insurance purposes so
I always thought there was 20 20 of
fluff in a lot of these websites that do
auction pricing but I think 20 discounts
reasonable
in aggregate over the last seven years
nothing has beat my watch collection in
the rest of my portfolio including all
my alternative asset classes including
crypto
um
nothing has beaten watches and so they
are liquid obviously I can't sell them
but I have to have a value associated
with them so I can put them into my
overall portfolio of of alternative
assets and I treat them just like I do
alternative asset classes like private
Equity or Investments I'm making
companies or in real estate
they are an alternative asset class and
So when you buy a watch
it has great value if you're if you do
the job as a collector to get
diversification and understand what
you're buying and I'm never embarrassed
to call someone like you or Paul Boutros
or many other collectors I know and say
I'm really getting trying to get my head
around this piece what do you think and
you get all kinds of opinions and you
want that information because that's the
market speaking to you before you pull
the trigger and where does it fit you
know a lot of the collectors I deal with
know my collection they know it inside
out they know what I own they say why
are you buying that you've already got
15 of those you know it's sort of that
kind of feedback that you want but yes
it's alternative asset class Kevin
O'Leary secret hints of success your
watch well if I see a journey on you you
could be a brain surgeon you could be an
astrophysicist you could be an artist
you could be a painter this is what I'm
talking about this is the magic of
collecting and the brand and the history
and the person in the story this is what
it's all about